[Applause]
[Music]
turkey a nation of more than 80 million
people has traditionally been considered
one of the most open and advanced muslim
democracies in the world for years it
was also one of the great economic
promises between 1999 and 2019 its
economy grew in real terms an average of
almost five percent per year an
expansion with the government supported
with a huge modernization plan to update
roads airports ports and all kinds of
infrastructure
[Music]
and so visualpolitik community turkey
became a middle-income country and an
investment magnate the economy
industrialized the country positioned
itself as a fashionable tourist
destination and istanbul became an
important financial hub
the ottoman economy was positioned as a
gateway one of the most common
connection points for accessing the
markets of russia the middle east and
central asia what's more the country was
a respected member of the international
community it was and as a member of nato
and the oecd and since 1995 has also had
a customs agreement with the european
union itself which gives it preferential
access to the huge european common
market so with all this in mind it can't
be surprising that in 2018 we would find
news reports like this one
turkey the great success story of the
international economy
since then however things have changed a
lot the economic boom that lifted
millions of people into the middle class
for two decades has begun to falter
and it seems that today the turkish
economy is facing a very severe currency
crisis in 2021 alone the turkish lira
has lost 50 percent of its value against
the dollar this is a nightmare that
threatens all the progress made by the
ottoman economy in recent decades and
that has made us on visualpolitik along
with our friends at value school ask
ourselves a question what has caused
such a debacle and take note because
this is not the typical case of a
government forcing its central bank to
create a lot of new money to finance its
level of public spending in the case of
turkey we are dealing with an entire
political and economic strategy a
totally deliberate plan so what exactly
is happening with the turkish economy
well let's take a look
the monetary debacle
throughout 2021 the turkish lira has
lost 50 percent of its value against the
dollar and this is not an isolated case
since erdogan assumed the presidency of
turkey in 2014 the lira has depreciated
by almost
90 percent
a situation that obviously is having
consequences we can highlight three main
ones
the first is that inflation has
skyrocketed for example official figures
point to an inflation rate of around 20
but private estimates indicate that it
could have already exceeded levels of 60
take a look at this
this has been that many families have
had to cut back on basic goods such as
meat or even bread at the same time
they're also having problems getting
hold of imported products such as
medicines
[Music]
secondly turkish savers are trying to
exchange the lira they earn as fast as
they can for dollars and gold this is
causing significant damage to the local
financial system on the one hand this
process accelerates the depreciation of
the lira and on the other hand when it
comes to cash withdrawals it contributes
to consuming the country's foreign
currency reserves something that in
itself may end up causing the government
to establish tough capital controls
and thirdly the collapse of the lira has
led to a huge flight of foreign capital
so that for example holdings of bonds
and shares in the hands of foreign
investors have plummeted by more than 70
in recent years check this out
and it doesn't end there in an attempt
to support the lira the turkish central
bank has intervened several times in the
market by selling foreign currencies
which has depleted the country's net
reserves in other words the turkish
economy is facing very very serious
problems and take note here because
there are more than a few investors
analysts and economists who expect
things to get even worse so then what on
earth is happening with the turkish
economy check this out
a matter of faith
i repeat the question what is happening
with the turkish economy well take a
look at this graph
is there anything that catches your
attention anything that strikes you as
surprisingly strange that's right even
though inflation is skyrocketing the
lira is plummeting turkey's central bank
is lowering interest rates in fact the
plan seems to be to cut them even
further which is exactly the opposite of
what is usually done in these situations
because in order to curb inflation
prevent capital flight and prevent the
dollar getting stronger which for
example makes foreign currency debt
harder to repay central banks usually
raise interest rates but turkey is doing
exactly the opposite so the question is
why well this all comes down to a type
of economic policy that is already known
as ergonomics this is the key factor
that explains the tremendous crisis that
the turkish lira is going through
[Music]
you see turkey's all-powerful president
is convinced that if the central bank
lowers the country's interest rates this
will eventually lead to lower levels of
inflation from his perspective the
process would be as follows lower
interest rates encourage investment
investment increases production which in
turn makes products cheaper boosts
exports and makes the country richer in
short we could say that for erdogan
lowering interest rates is tantamount to
subsidising investment never mind what
happens to i don't know supplies raw
materials foreign investment or the
purchasing power of turkey's own savers
what we call exchange rate rise today
and fall tomorrow what we call inflation
rises today and falls tomorrow
production and employment are permanent
risip tayyip erdogan president of turkey
and that is exactly why this president
has been pushing the turkish central
bank to lower interest rates for his
entire term in office and particularly
during 2021 in fact the president's
ultimate goal is to eventually set
interest dates at zero and take note
because erdogan has already dismissed
five central bank top officials for not
agreeing to follow his plan
he doesn't understand the economy and
the people around him don't understand
the economy he is on another planet in
another universe amit davao gotoghu
former prime minister of turkey and
former ally of recep tayyip erdogan
so then what's wrong with erdogan where
does he get the idea that the cheaper
the interest rates are the better why
does he think that the best way to deal
with an inflationary scenario and the
collapse of the lira is to lower
interest rates even further well all
this more or less has to do with an
ideological line of economic action that
emerged at the end of the 20th century
and is known as islamic economics a
theory that regards interest rates as
the mother of all evils check this out
islamic economy
the first thing we need to know is that
the quran strongly condemns reba or
lending money for profit and that is why
the shiaria isramic law considers that
money is a simple instrument of exchange
and as such cannot be used to make a
profit so fixing a predetermined and
fixed rate of interest could be contrary
to islamic law
now although the quran condemns usury it
does not clearly define it so
historically many islamic jurists
distinguish between excessively
exploitative money lending and those
with reasonable interest rates that
allowed for example the operation of
monetary foundations in the ottoman
empire itself which offered credit with
interest rates and later of real banks
all over the muslim world
however everything started to get
complicated in the second half of the
20th century when the theory of islamic
economics emerged which besides being
influenced by marxist ideas returned to
an extreme interpretation of the riba of
usury in other words it condemns
interest rates
and remember this is not just a question
of shall we say morality the same
economic theory argues that interest
rates end up causing more inflation more
poverty and less economic growth and you
know what erdogan is a self-confessed
follower of islamic economics in fact he
has publicly defended his war on
interest rates by making statements like
this one
there is a nas a quranic decree on this
issue so is it up to you or me erdogan
president of turkey
[Music]
in other words he has defended his
political programme as a religious
obligation that no good muslim should
question this is the great challenge
facing turkey that is causing so many
problems
[Music]
a president who has taken control of
every major institution in the country
including the central bank the
universities and the vast majority of
the media a president who is committed
to a type of economic policy the results
of which are getting worse and worse and
a president does not seem willing to
change his mind without going back too
far at the beginning of december 2021
this news came out
turkey's finance minister resigns amid
the plunge in lira lufty elvan resigns
and is replaced by nuredin nabati an
erdogan loyalist lufty elvan who was
seen as the last voice of economic
orthodoxy in the turkish leader's
cabinet has to be relieved of his duties
and to further increase uncertainty and
perhaps country risk check out the
turkish leader's next resolution
erdogan announces the drafting of a new
constitution in turkey in 2022
in light of what we've seen it doesn't
seem that much can be expected
[Music]
and there you have it visualpolitik
viewers this is exactly what explains
the crisis in turkey of course not
everyone is so pessimistic and there are
those who point that if things stabilize
and there is possibly even a change of
government in the next elections things
could improve very quickly for example
the case of bbva
bbva launches a takeover bid for half
the turkish bank guarantee that it does
not control for 2.249 billion euros
[Music]
but now the question is over to you will
turkey manage to escape from this
difficult situation does it seem like a
good time to invest in turkey or do you
consider the country risk to be too
great leave your answers below and you
know if you found this video interesting
don't forget to like and subscribe to
all of us here at visualpolitik many
thanks to our friends also at value
school for their collaboration and
making this interesting video all the
best and i'll see you next time
[Music]